[Applaus]
endlich angekommen aus afghanistan
flughafen berlin vergangener freitag
bis zuletzt hatten die helfer gebannt ob
es dieses mal klappt ahmad am inn
dschabari hatte jahrelang für die
bundeswehr gearbeitet doch die hatte ihm
in afghanistan zurück gelassen mit
seiner frau und seinen beiden kindern
ist der über pakistan nach deutschland
gekommen
ich kann meine gefühle gar nicht in
worte fassen ich habe im flugzeug
geweint wurde ihr heimatland verlassen
dann habe ich gemerkt dass ich euch habe
das ist jetzt meine zweite heimat
er ist in sicherheit doch viele seiner
kollegen und ihre familien fürchten in
afghanistan noch um ihr leben
ich bin wirklich empört weil tausende
ortskräfte afghanistan zurückgelassen
worden sind darum kümmert ihr euch nicht
um sie man darf nicht wochenlang mit
einer entscheidung warten bis sie
getötet werden
ich bitte die deutsche regierung tut
etwas für meine kollegen
rückblick die bundesregierung startet
eine luftbrücke um ihre ortskräfte aus
afghanistan heraus zu holen fiel zu spät
um alle in sicherheit zu bringen als die
taliban kabul und auch den flughafen
vollständig unter ihrer kontrolle haben
macht die deutsche regierung ein großes
versprechen
werden können werden wir nicht vergessen
und dass wir uns auch weiter bemühen die
noch in afghanistan verbliebenen
personen heraus zu bekommen dass wir sie
identifizieren und denen die schutz
brauchen diesen schutz auch
gewährleisten und zwar so lange bis alle
in sicherheit sind für die wir in
afghanistan verantwortung tragen doch
das versprechen sei nicht zu halten sagt
der grünen politiker omid nouripour
man ist jetzt nicht mehr herr der lage
wir sind in den händen der taliban es
gehört auch dazu dass wir eingestehen
dass wir wahrscheinlich nicht mehr allen
denen wir schutz versprochen haben bei
den schutz geben können darunter könnten
auch viele ehemalige kolleginnen von
achmadschah bari sein mit denen er im
medienzentrum zusammengearbeitet hat
seite an seite mit bundeswehr-soldaten
haben sie einen informationskrieg gegen
die taliban geführt damals gab ahmad dem
zdf ein interview
wir wollen dass die menschen verstehen
dass es uns um den aufbau einer
zivilgesellschaft geht das in
afghanistan soldaten ihr blut vergießen
damit man hier irgendwann einmal
anständig leben kann
alles vergebens drei jahre später muss
sich ahmad vor den taliban verstecken
wie erreichen ihn ende august irgendwo
in kabul
manchmal denke ich dass mir die taliban
den kopf abschneiden und ihn als
geschenk an meine familie schicken
mehrfach fährt auch markt mit seiner
frau und den kindern zum flughafen doch
dort gibt es kein durchkommen
es herrscht chaos
als er es dann endlich in den flughafen
schafft akzeptiert ein bundeswehrsoldat
seine papiere nicht
ich habe ihnen die dokumente gezeigt
dass sich ausreise berechtigt bin doch
sie haben uns auf dem flughafen
rausgeschmissen
ein fataler irrtum wie die bundeswehr
später einräumt nach dem ende der
luftbrücke schlägt sich ahmad auf dem
landweg richtung pakistan durch mit
papieren der deutschen regierung
passiert er 15 checkpoints der taliban
und schaffte es mit seiner familie über
die grenze
ich bin gerade der todesgefahr entkommen
da bin ich richtig froh
gerade einmal 1000 menschen konnte die
bundesregierung in den vergangenen sechs
wochen aus afghanistan heraus holen viel
zu wenige kritisiert die
hilfsorganisation
mission lifeline wie auch ahmad
unterstützt hat
als die bundesregierung muss jetzt
schleunigst
alles dafür tun und sie muss auch
erklären was sie tut weil bisher erklärt
sie nämlich gar nicht was sie tun um
alle box kräfte herauszuholen es muss
einfach spiel schneller gerettet werden
man kann hier mit 200 leuten pro woche
anfangen dessen witz dass afghanistan
desaster soll vor einen
untersuchungsausschuss darauf bestehen
die grünen es gab eine große kette von
fehlern im afghanistan einsatz wir
werden auch aufarbeiten müssen was seit
beginn des abzuges und in der
evakuierung war das schief gelaufen was
es braucht ganz dringend politische
aufarbeitung damit sich solche fehler in
ähnlichen situationen einfach nicht mehr
wiederholen
ahmad will seinen landsleuten jetzt von
deutschland aus helfen und er will sich
einen job suchen vielleicht wieder bei
der bundeswehr